>> From the Library of
Congress in in Washington, D.C.
>> Kelly link was born in
Miami, Florida, where she lived
in a quote half-finished
development for seven years;
a place where her father
chased peacocks off the roof
of his car in the morning.
The rest of her childhood was
spent moving around from Tennessee
to Pennsylvania to North Carolina.
This is so good because
I speak slower.
I really wish you were
with me all the time.
[ Laughter ]
As a teenager, she spent
a lot of time in malls
and owned a pet boa
constrictor named Baby.
Her parents loved books.
They could always be talked into
reading just one more chapter
of the Narnia books, one
more chapter of the Hobbit.
"I became deeply attached to an
edition of the Wonderful Wizard
of Oz that belonged to
the dentist's office,"
she told the New York Times,
"It wasn't in great shape,
by which I mean someone had bled
on it, maybe multiple someone's.
She wasn't happy about it, but my
mother finally bought it for me
so we could bring it home.
Shortly after graduating college,
Kelly won a sweepstakes while living
in Scotland and got free
travel around the world.
This is true.
She had to answer three
basic geographic questions
and then a forth question
to break a tie
which was why do you want
to go around the world?
And she wrote because
you can't go through it.
[ Laughter ]
Kelly met her Husband, Gavin Grant,
working at a used book
store in Boston.
And in 2000 they founded Small
Beer Press, a leading publisher
of literary fantasy an science
fiction including her first two
critically acclaimed collections of
stories Stranger than Fiction 2001
and Magic for Beginners 2005.
Kelly's many writing accolades
include three Hugo Awards,
a Nebula Award, Locus Award, a World
Fantasy Award, and a NEA fellowship
in creative writing, which is a
highly competitive fellowship based
solely on artistic
excellence and selected
through an anonymous review process.
And any questions about the program
you can ask us right over there
at the literature staff at the NEA.
My name is Amy Stolls, by the way,
and I'm the director of literature
at the National Endowment
for the Arts or the NEA
which sponsors this
poetry and [inaudible]
at the National Book Festival.
And I first came across
Kelly's work in 2006
when she was an applicant
to our program.
The story she submitted was the The
Hortlak from Magic for Beginners,
still one of my favorite stories.
And I remember when it came up for
review before the panel I loved it
so much I was really to give the
hairy eyeball to anyone who didn't
like it, but they all
did, every one of them.
And in 2009 I got to work with Kelly
when she agreed to be a panelist
for us and judge the submissions
that year, and I was such a huge fan
that I kind of felt like a
teenager who was getting to hang
with her favorite pop star.
[ Laughter ]
And there were lots of others
like my at the time who insisted
that all their friends
read her books
and we couldn't understand why
she wasn't super famous yet.
"How can you not know about her?"
We'd say. Well now more of
you do, many, many more.
And if you don't, you will.
This year she was named a
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize
for her latest collection
of stories, Get in Trouble,
which garnered starred reviews in
Publishers Weekly and [inaudible]
and elsewhere and appeared on a
slew of top recommended reading
and best of the year lists.
As with her previous books, it's a
collection of very real characters
in very real relationships
dealing with very real problems.
But the realities she paints are so
often tinged with something magical
or otherworldly or
superhero-ish or just strange
and funny and inexplicable.
Publishers Weekly describes her
mix of humor and existential dread
as if [inaudible] were hosting
Saturday Night Live and I love that.
I'll make one final plug for
Kelly and the NEA and that is
that we just added Kelly's
book Pretty Monsters
to our NEA Big Read program
which supports community read
programs around the country.
And again, if you'd like to
know more about that program
or just find our more fun
background information on Kelly,
and I took some of that
information from our website
for this introduction,
ask us after or check
out our website at NeaBigRead.org.
And with that please
welcome Kelly Link.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. Thank you for
having me here for this.
Timekeeper can I ask how
long and how many minutes...
>> [Inaudible].
>> OK. All right.
Awesome. All right.
So I am going to talk a little
bit about this collection
and about what I write in
general and then there's sort
of an audience participation
part and I'm going
to do two very short readings, but
after that there can be questions.
I'm going to try and leave a
bunch of time for questions.
And in order to give you an idea
of the things that I'm happy
to talk about, I have been writing
-this is my forth collection
of short stories.
Of the stories in Get in
Trouble, four were written
for young adult editors for
anthologies of young adult stories,
four were written for
literary magazines,
and one of the stories
I wrote for myself.
And so I am happy to talk
about young adult publishing
or about young literary
magazines or about science fiction
because when I started publishing
I started in science fiction.
For years I was the editor of the
anthology series Year's Best Fantasy
and Horror with my husband Gavin and
with Ellen Datlow, and so we used
to read very widely
any kind of story
that had any fantastic
element for consideration.
I am also happy to talk to
you about writing in general.
I live in North Hampton,
Massachusetts.
My working method is as often as
possible during the week I meet
up with two other writers, both
of them young adult writers,
Holly Black and Cassandra Clare.
And we either go to coffee shops
or we go to one of their houses
and we sit and all work together,
by which I mean we all sit
and either typewrite or all sit
at our laptops and type and talk
about what we're working on.
And I think that sometimes people
who write themselves or even people
when they imagine the writer
imagines writers is working
in isolation, and I have
tried that and I hated it
and I never got anything done.
And in fact, the only way for
me to get work done is to be
in the company of other people
who are doing their own thing
so that I feel that I'm in a very
casual office with a bunch of sofas.
So I'm happy to talk
about my working method.
So think about that.
Think about any questions
that might come up.
I would love to be helpful
to people who are interested
in writing or in publishing.
I can also talk about small press
publishing because my husband
and I have been running Small Beer
for fifteen years now and that is
as much my working
life as the writing is.
So having said all that,
what I'm going to start off
with is a series of
horoscope readings.
A friend of mine who also lives
in North Hampton that I work
with sometimes, Jedediah Berry,
wrote a project -Kickstarted
a project
for something called the Family
Arcana which was a card deck
of fifty-two very short stories
about a family in the Northeast,
in the mountains in the Northeast.
And he asked twelve writers
to provide one horoscope each
as a bonus level for the Kickstarter
and so I got to write Gemini
and enjoyed it so much that I ended
up writing eleven more
horoscope short stories.
And these were eventually published
in a magazine called Monkey Business
that comes out twice; first in
Japan in Japanese, it's a mixture
of American writers and
new Japanese writers,
and then they publish it
again in the U.S. in English.
And so what I'll ask is if
anybody wants to yell out a sign
and I will read you your horoscope.
>> Capricorn.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to do six and
then we'll come back to it.
So Capricorn -and two of these,
by the way, I'm just going
to read something very short from
the collection Get in Trouble.
Capricorn.
All those rock cairns to
mark your good progress.
Who comes along behind
you to knock them down?
Nevermind.
This isn't a horror movie.
Under those cairns
only the sturdy dirt.
The only thing hidden,
what you choose to hide.
Keep going, keep going.
Make dinosaur noises
when you get sad.
Everyone gets sad sometimes.
When it gets dark, whistle a
tune or tell a knock-knock joke,
see who answers, mark the time.
Your map brings you home
if you read it right.
If there's a knock at the door
later on, don't open it or do.
Did something follow
you the whole way back?
Was that why you left those markers?
Consult your map again.
Anybody else?
[ Crowd yelling ]
I heard Torus...
[ Laughter ]
most clearly, which says
something about Torus.
[ Laughter ]
Stay in bed today.
Let's stay in bed.
I'll tell you a story about the
grasshopper who loved the ant.
I will bring you peaches on a
gold plate, wine in a tooth mug.
I have hidden your phone.
Eat, drink and be married
because the world will go
on without you whether
or not you wish it to.
The world will go on without you.
Sure footed child who
obeyed all the rules,
what reward will satisfy
your greedy heart?
Everything you need is here.
The world will exist tomorrow;
the dishes in the sink,
the mountains with
the clouds upon them.
All right.
[ Crowd yelling ]
Scorpio.
All right.
So Scorpio is -I'm going
to read something very,
very short from the book.
This is from a story called
I Can See Right Through You.
And I will say that some of these
I wrote for specific individuals
and so the actual horoscope itself
I wrote for Holly Black and it's
about DND, but the story
is about some movie stars
and this is a very
short piece of it.
Maggie tells the demon lover
a story: Two girls and, look,
they've found a Ouija board.
They make a list of questions.
One girl is pretty.
One girl is not really
part of this story.
She's lost her favorite sweater.
Two girls each touching
lightly the planchette.
Is anyone here?
Where did I put my blue sweater?
Will anyone ever love me?
Things like that.
They ask their questions.
The planchette drifts.
They start the list over again.
Is anyone here?
Will I be famous?
Where is my blue sweater?
The planchette jerks
under their fingers.
M-E. Maggie says, "Did you do that?"
The other girl says she didn't.
M-E-G-G-I-E.
"It's talking to you,"
the other girl says.
M-E-G-G-I-E H-E-L -hello.
Maggie says, "Hello?'
The planchette moves.
There is something animal about it.
H-E-L -hello, I am with
you, I am with you always.
They write it all down.
M-E-G -Maggie O I will
love you always.
"Who is this?"
she says. "Who are you?"
I-S-E -I see you.
A pause. Then: I-W-I -I will
Maggie O I will be with you always.
"Are you doing this?"
Maggie says to the other girl.
She shakes her head.
M-E-G -Maggie wait.
The other girl says, "I just want
to know where my sweater is."
O-W-A-I -O wait and I will come.
They wait.
Will there be a knock
at the bedroom door?
But no one comes.
No one is coming.
I-A-M -I am with you always.
No one is here with them.
The sweater will never be found.
The other grows up, lives
a long and happy life.
Maggie goes out to L.A.
and meets the demon lover.
W-A-I-T. After that the only
thing the planchette says over
and over is Maggie's name.
It's all very romantic.
All right.
And let's do two or three
more of the horoscopes.
>> Ares.
[ Laughter ]
>> I heard Aries.
All right.
First sign of the Zodiac.
First love, basement dweller, grudge
holder, light-fingered traveler,
you give too much of yourself away,
you trip over your own sweet words.
And when you don't [inaudible]
honey tongue oh golden throat,
the tastes of the thing you
loved grows ever more bitter.
You came in each morning
early and told me secrets
that the liar had told you; Lyle
Lovett just married Julia Roberts.
And now if the world
were a better place,
you could settle down
and live in it.
Music belongs to you
when nothing else does.
I haven't see you in
such a long time.
Have you forgiven your father yet?
And let's do one or two more.
[ Yelling ]
Pisces I heard.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like I'm rewarding
people who have pipes.
I don't really have pipes so.
And I'm looking for Pisces.
I'll do Gemini and see
if I can turn up Pisces.
You would have to tell me
if this is typical of Pisces
that it just sort of gets lost.
Oh wait, here's Pisces.
Here we go.
Pisces. Some people, every
house they live in turns
out to be haunted, and so
maybe it isn't the houses.
[ Laughter ]
[Inaudible].
You see a death in every water
stain, a passenger in every shadow.
Why send away for a decoder ring?
Every message is plain to you.
Every friend outstays their welcome.
Every wound felt as if you
had inflicted it yourself.
Some days, some years you'd like to
retreat from the world altogether,
but of course you know better.
Nutshell, palace, island, nunnery.
Where is the shelter with
its roof so waterproofed,
the door barred so tight?
Where is the soul so whole that
the world can't find its way in?
Where is the world where things
are only ever themselves alone?
Go on looking, I'll come with you.
And now I feel that in terms
of presentation and talking
about this book because one
these are short stories,
and two because mostly the stuff
in it that is really the kernel
at the heart of the story are
things that I made up; ghost stories
or monsters or fantastic things.
It's a little bit hard to talk about
the research that went into it.
In fact, the most research that
I have ever done for a piece
of writing I think
was for the horoscopes
because I really didn't know
a lot about most of the signs.
So I figured what I would
do rather than talking
about the stories themselves,
unless you guys have
specific questions later on,
is that I would tell you a
couple of the ghost stories,
the true ghost stories,
that were inspirations
for some of the stories in here.
I've kind of made a hobby
of collecting other
people's ghost stories.
And when I write it's
not necessarily
that I'm including these
ghost stories verbatim,
it's just that I am trying to
capture something of the feeling
of the ghost stories that
people have been telling me.
So the first two ghost stories
that I was going to tell you are
about a friend, and I asked if I
could tell these and she said yes.
She grew up in a house in a
small town in Massachusetts,
which is not too far
from where I live now.
And she said it was a
house that during the years
that she lived there, nobody
in her family really liked,
they all thought it was
kind of a bad place.
And she has a lot of
stories about this house
and these are two of the stores.
The first is a story
about Christmas Eve.
And it was a house very typical of
New England houses which was a stack
or row of rooms in the
downstairs with a hallway
with a staircase going to
the upstairs where, again,
there was sort of a row of
rooms going towards the back,
they were all bedrooms
and then a bathroom.
And her bedroom was the first
bedroom at the top of the stairs
and she had in fact moved her bed
away the wall next to the hallway
because the hallway
gave her a bad feeling
and so she slept on the other wall.
But from her bed, if her room was
open, she could see that hallway.
And so Christmas night she
said everybody had gone to bed,
all the kids, her sisters and
brother and she had gone to bed
and her mother was downstairs.
And she said that she
was lying in bed
and heard somebody begin
to come up the stairs.
And she said when they got to
the top of the stairs she should
of been able to see
them on the landing,
but in fact there was nobody there.
And so she was sort of trying
to figure out what was going on
and then she heard the
footsteps start to go back
down the staircase again.
And she said there were
twelve stairs in the flight,
and so she counted and she heard
them go all the way back down again,
and then she heard them
come up the stairs again.
And she counted and when she
should have been able to see them
on the landing, there
was still nobody there.
And so she said she lay there
watching the hallway as somebody
or something went down the stairs
and then back up the stairs again
until finally her mother who was in
the living room downstairs yelled,
"Would you kids go
the hell to sleep?
It's late!"
And she said that the
footsteps stopped.
And she said that she waited and
she still couldn't go to sleep.
And about fifteen minutes
later they started up again.
She said it just kept on
like that all night long.
And then the other story, one of the
things she had to do when she was
in her senior year of high school
was keep a scrapbook about her life.
And so she had gone to a U2 concert,
and she was sitting at her desk
and she was putting the ticket
-she was drawing some stuff
and writing about it.
And when she went to glue the
ticket into her scrapbook,
the glue stick wasn't there.
And she's a very organized person
still, she says she always has been.
And so she looked and it was not on
the table where she thought it was.
And so she looked around the desk.
She looked to the side of the desk.
She looked behind the
desk, she looked under it
and there was no glue stick.
And so she sort of turned
around to look at the room
and it was lying on her pillow.
And so she went and took the
glue stick and brought it back
to the desk and she put the ticket
in, and she did a couple more pages.
And then she reached for the
glue stick, and once again,
the glue stick wasn't there.
And so she looked under
the desk and beside it,
she looked at the pillow
and it was not there.
And so she went downstairs and
she was very discombobulated,
so she said, "I'll make
myself a sandwich."
And so she went through the living
room through the dining room
into the kitchen and opened
up the refrigerator door.
And when she pulled
open the cheese drawer,
the glue stick was
in the cheese drawer.
[ Laughter ]
And so a couple of -actually, last
Halloween I got to do an event
at the Harvard Book Store where
they turned off all the lights
and they had me and one of my
favorite writers, Samantha Hunt,
come and do a very short reading
and tell some ghost
stories with the lights off.
And then at midnight they allowed
everybody who'd come to the reading
to go around the store
with flashlights and shot
from midnight to 1 AM by flashlight.
It was a great event.
It was a ton of fun.
And I told one of those stories
and afterwards a woman came up
and she asked me what town
my friend had lived in.
She said, "Oh it's
not the same town.
I thought it might
be the same house."
[ Laughter ]
And she said that she had
lived in a very similar house
and she had lived there
with her mother, her cousins
and their parents and
her grandmother.
And she and her cousin -actually,
I think her house had a hallway
down the center, she
had a bedroom one side
and her cousin had a
bedroom on the other side.
And late at night when she
was supposed to be sleeping,
they couldn't cross the hallway
because it made too much noise
and so instead they would
each sit in their doorway
and they would play
cards in the hallway.
And they were doing that
one night and looked up
and somebody was standing at the
end of the hallway, it was a woman
in very old fashioned clothing
and they didn't not recognize her,
it was not their grandmother.
And she said, "Don't you think you
kids should be in bed right now?"
And then this wave of terror came
over them and so they both started,
without saying anything,
leaving the cards
in the hallway, went to their beds.
And she said she got in bed and she
closed her eyes very, very tightly
and she felt the person come
down the hallway and stand
in the doorway just looking in
at her, but she wouldn't look.
And she said after that
they never talked about it
and they never played
cards in the hallway again.
[ Laughter ]
But years later they were at
a -everybody had come home
for Thanksgiving and she was in the
dining room setting up some stuff
and she heard somebody
drop a lot of plates
in the kitchen and break them.
And so she came into the
kitchen and it was her cousin
that had dropped all these plates
and it was because her mother
and her cousin's mother had been
talking and one of them had said
to the other, "I saw that
ghost again last night."
[ Laughter ]
And apparently saw the ghost,
but until this moment nobody
had ever talked about it.
[ Laughter ]
We live in a very old farmhouse in
North Hampton that has no ghosts,
but any time that I drive through a
small town in Massachusetts I think,
"I bet there are a lot of
ghosts in these houses."
So I'm going to a couple
more horoscopes.
>> Leo.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Who wouldn't prefer to be
the star of a romcom instead
of splatter her Thin Man
movies over [inaudible]?
Every present I ever gave you,
you divine the contents before
the lid came off the box.
So you know the course of true
love never did run smooth.
Into every life a little
reign of terror must fall.
Into every life.
Remember when we didn't
know each other?
Our paths never crossed.
I hate to have to leave,
but here we are.
Take good care.
Watch old screwballs.
Nevermind the zombies,
they're from the other movie,
the one I watched coming
home on the plane.
When I get home, we'll sleep in.
>> Gemini.
This is the one that I wrote for
Jed's project for the Family Arcana.
And the idea with Family Arcana
is that you either shuffle it
and deal yourself a hand or
else you do it with a group
and sort of takes turns reading.
And so the story which is made
up of little stories
changes every single time.
It's a ton of fun.
So the horoscopes that
people wrote were ones
that people could add
in if they wanted.
Last night you had a realization;
no one will ever love you
as much as you love you.
On the other hand, no one will hate
you as much as you hate yourself.
When you fell asleep you dreamed you
heard two voices in a room talking
about the possibility of
life on other planets.
When you went to look though,
the only one there was you,
the other you everyone likes better.
Half of you is mortal,
half of you is divine.
Does it matter which half is which?
One of you is going to be lonely
some day, but let's not think
about that right now, OK?
OK. That's actually my favorite.
[ Laughter ]
I really like doppelgangers.
Somebody else?
[ Crowd yelling ]
Aquarius. Look at you up
in that hot air balloon.
Isn't the world awfully
small from up there?
Easier to love too.
You could pick up all
of those trees,
those little four-legged beasts,
those picnic goers or
military battalions.
Looking down, who can
even tell the difference?
And put them all in your pocket.
Maintain your distance, I've been
sick with love since last Tuesday.
You wouldn't want to catch this.
Besides, me down here and you
up there, it's so much easier
to believe this will
all work out one day.
You'll lower a sturdy rope,
I'll tie it around my waste.
Everything you could ever need
I'll pack it all in a knapsack
and you can haul it up too.
Ballast [phonetic].
Throw it back over when
you need to go higher.
>> Libra.
>> Libra. There you go again
handing out bits of your soul
as if you thought other people
might treat them better than you do.
Were you hoping for
something in return?
Its true life isn't
fair, neither is it easy.
Yes I know you are astonished
by that, but let's move on.
Bad things happen to everyone
and the good as well, see?
The party wasn't as much fun
as you thought it would be.
Too many argumentative drunks, not
enough dancing, what was the point?
Pack your friends into taxis.
Go over the things
you should have said.
Wash the makeup off of your face.
Someone in the next garden
over is singing the saddest
song, but oh what a voice.
All right.
>> Virgo.
>> Virgo. I heard Virgo.
Guardian of the threshold, I
salute your calculating heart,
your wistful brain crammed
with dreams, delights,
and other people's problems.
I know you'd like to
set all the order,
but suppose one person could
accomplish such a task,
how would you go about it?
Take down the shower
curtain and bleach it.
Make sandwiches for the hungry.
Sweep all the unrighteous
into the fireplace.
But dear heart, scheming brain, take
over one world and the other falls
into chaos, disaster, meanness.
Even your friends get
things wrong sometimes,
give you foul water instead
of fresh, poison instead
of the honeycomb, when what you had
asked for is tinder and a match.
And I've got Cancer
and Sagittarius left.
>> Sagittarius.
Curious monkey paw stuck again
between the rock and the hard place.
Did you see something glitter and
did you think you found truth?
Maybe it is and you've got
hold of it, but so what?
You still have to let go
if you want to get free.
Somedays the truth will slam
into you like a foot in the belly
and just kick the hell out of you.
Other days it's a karaoke number
you've got done word perfect,
but no one likes the
way you sing it.
Listen, I don't want you to stop
yelling that the truth is out there,
just is it necessary
to go down every alley
like some goonish George [inaudible]
at the man in the yellow hat
in that old book by
Raymond Chandler.
I know you'd do anything for me
so let this one go just this once.
And then I'm going to
tell one more ghost story
and then we'll do Cancer.
I'm Cancer.
So this ghost story is a story that
somebody told me, I don't know,
maybe ten years ago, and it's
still the story that I think
of whenever I sit down to
write and I think I want
to write something really scary.
And it's a story that someone
told me at a dinner party.
She said that she lived in a small
town in Texas and that for years,
sort of between the ages of ten and
fourteen, she had a recurring dream.
And in this dream she would
be walking down the street
of her home town and a man
would be walking towards her.
And he didn't always look
the same from dream to dream,
sometimes he was older or younger,
sometimes he was clean shaven,
sometimes he had a beard, but
she always recognized him.
And she always knew that
when they finally met
that something very
bad would happen.
And so one night when she had
this -and the other thing was
that she would always wake up
before they encountered each other
and said anything.
So one night she had this dream
and for the very first
time they met face to face
and she said, "What is your name?"
And he said, "My name is Sammy."
And she was so afraid at that
point that she woke herself up
and she could not go back to sleep
so she went to her sister's bedroom
and she said, "I just
had a really bad dream.
Can I get in bed and
sleep with you?"
And her sister said, "What is it?
Is it Sammy?"
and she said, "How
do you know Sammy?"
and her sister said,
"I don't know Sammy,
you just brought him
in the room with you."
So she turned on the
lights and realized
that in fact her sister was still
asleep so she woke her up and said,
"What did you say to me?"
and her sister said, "I
didn't say anything to you.
I was asleep."
And the end of that story is
she never had that dream again.
[ Laughter ]
But after I heard that story,
I laid awake for many nights.
[ Laughter ]
Flat on my back until
finally I called a friend
and told my friend this
story after which I was able
to sleep and my friend was not.
[ Laughter ]
So I tell that story as
often as I can in hopes
that you too will be
unable to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
And eventually everybody will know
this story, even people named Sammy.
So I'm going to tell
you the Cancer horoscope
and then I hope you
have some questions.
Everyone loves a good story.
Scuba divers take paperback
novels to read on the way down.
All those Stations of the Cross.
Once you've opened a book under
water though, don't bother trying
to find your place on dry land.
Anyway darling, it's
better downwards wetter.
Why are you always crying anyway?
Is it because you know
what happens or is it
because the pages are
all stuck together
and you're worried
you'll never find out?
If the sea gets too far
away, fill up a basin
and take a long bath,
let the water get cold.
If the ending is sad, don't tell me.
And I'll say that that one -years
ago there's a friend of mine,
the writer Karen Joy Fowler,
told me that scuba divers actually
do take paperback novels with them
on dives and you can read them
as you are sort of waiting
for equilibrium for your oxygen,
etc. And then aboard the ship there
will be a collection, a library,
of all these paperbacks that
have been read under water,
which you can no longer read on
dry land, but when you go back
down under water you
can read them again,
and I thought that was incredible.
So I've been waiting a long
time to use that in a story
and it seemed appropriate
for Cancer.
So does anybody have questions
about writing or about publishing
or about young adult
genre in general?
Yep.
>> [Inaudible]?
>> That's a great question.
So when I write short stories,
does the fantastic element
come first or the real?
I think what comes first
is often something weird,
maybe a fantastic element or it may
just be sort of an idea of some sort
of strange thing that happens to
somebody which then I can sort
of begin to add a fantastic
element to.
I think at least the stories that I
like best there is
often a supernatural
or a fantastic element it.
There's some stuff which feels
much more like everyday life,
and then there's stuff which is
neither supernatural nor real,
but is just kind of
what I almost think
of as the most interesting
kind of gossip,
the things that happen to people.
For example, my sister once told
me a story about a friend of hers
who went to a wedding and stayed
in a B&B and there was a lot
of taxidermy in her bedroom.
And so every night, she stayed
there I think two nights,
the first night there was a lot
of weird wrestling, and she turned
on the light and there was nothing.
The second night she
heard more wrestling.
She turned on the light and
there were beetles flooding
out of this piece of taxidermy.
And I said, "What did she do?
And my sister said, "I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
The only part of the story that
stuck with her was the beetles.
And so things like that I often
think sure you can have a ghost
story, but there needs to
be something beside a ghost.
There has to be something which
you think, "Yeah that could happen.
That would be terrible,
but it could happen."
And then somehow that balances
out the fantastic element.
And then usually the
last thing is...
[ Laughter ]
Thinking about the kind of people
who are either causing the things
to happen or who the
things are happening to.
And thinking about people
and their lives come last,
but it usually takes the most work.
Yeah?
>> Yeah, I'm a big fan
of you and John Crowley.
>> Yeah?
>> And I noticed that you
published his Endless Things.
>> Yes.
>> And I didn't know if there as
an interesting story behind that,
and if there isn't, I was curious...
[ Laughter ]
Your writing and your publishing,
what's the relationship
between the two?
Does one fuel the other?
Are they parallel things,
activities?
>> Sure. So we published the last
book in a sequence by John Crowley,
who also has a long happy career in
sort of more traditional publishing,
and he came to us I think
because I'm not entirely sure.
We knew each other, I am
a big admire of his work.
One of his books, Little Big,
is one of my favorite novels.
And I think he wanted to do the
book in a very particular way
and he wanted to run off this
series and meanwhile he was embarked
on these other projects for his long
time editor and so we got to do it.
I think it was not a book that
required a lot of editing.
And the only other interesting thing
about it was that he found the art
for the cover which was an image by
the photographer Rosamond Purcell
which was perfect which indicated
to me that he had a very clear idea
of the book as an object as
well as the end of a sequence.
And we ran our first Kickstarter
in the spring which was
for another weird project
that he wanted to do.
He is somebody that I
would be happy to work
with anytime he has
something that doesn't fit
in with his regular
publishing schedule.
And the project that we
Kickstarted will come out;
it's his loose translation of a
very old book, The Chemical Wedding,
and again he found an artist
that he wanted to work with,
it's what you call profusely
illustrated this artist.
And I also love his short
stories; if he ever wanted
to do another collection, we
would be very happy to publish it.
In terms of publishing, I
spent about a third of my time
on Small Beer work
editing novels or working
on cover design or
reading submissions.
And we've gotten to
publish Le Guin, Joan Aiken,
Karen Joy Fowler, Ted Chiang.
And some debut writers like Sofia
Samatar and Nicole Kornher-Stace.
So part of it is just
I really like the work
of producing physical books,
but it's also, as a reader,
I get to work with a lot of people
that I would have killed to sort
of work with in some capacity,
except we don't have
to kill to do it.
[ Laughter ]
Yes?
>> Hi. You mentioned at the
beginning of your talk -I'm sorry,
I'm like really short
and struggling.
You mentioned at the
beginning of your talk
that you write specific
stories for young adults.
>> Yeah.
>> And then specific stories
for literary magazines
and stuff like that.
So what do you consciously
do differently when you write
for each I guess genre, and
do you have a preference?
>> I don't.
I realized I think as I was
putting this book together
that sometimes what I'll do
is I'll tackle a sort of idea
from the direction of a
young adult sort of thinking
if it's a young adult project and
then I will often come back to it
as an adult project with sort
of the same thematic material.
And a long time ago I heard
an editor describe young adult
as any narrative in which
somebody is experiencing something
for the first time; figuring
out something about themselves,
finding a sphere in which they want
to exist, moving into that sphere,
coming into a certain kind of power,
forming long-lasting relationships
that are voluntary, make
a family for one's self
or having an experience
which is sort
of a first betrayal or
something like that.
I think that the difference with
an adult story is you get to write
about people who maybe this is
more recursive, maybe this is more
of a pattern with them, maybe it's
something that has happened over
and over again or maybe this time
is the time that is different.
I think all stories in some way are
about the moment in somebody's life
where something happens which is so
dramatic that it becomes a story.
So there's a lot of overlap between
young adult and adult stories,
I think the difference is -Holly
Black said to me, we were talking
about the two different
kinds of stories, she says,
"Well I always read young adult
stories I always think they'll
probably be OK, they'll
figure stuff out."
[ Laughter ]
And I think when you read stories
that are adult stories you think,
"Oh buddy that was your last shot."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know that you
can recover from that.
So that's the difference;
it's you think
that person is a little more fixed
in their life and maybe has things
that have lasted a little longer
that are at stake for them.
But because all adults were
at some point young adults,
there is something universal about
writing from the point of view
of a young adult character or
about writing about those concerns.
I think that for many
people who like
to read the reason why young
adult literature is so popular is
because you felt really
strongly when you were that age
and those emotions and that
feeling is still accessible
to you no matter how old you are.
You think, "oh yeah,
I remember that."
In fact, some of you might
think, "I still feel that way.
That is a feeling that I have."
So I hope that...
>> Thank you.
>> Your welcome.
>> I've always liked how vivid
the settings of your stories are.
Do you ever go to, I guess,
evocative places in your own life
like haunted houses, old
buildings, things like that?
>> Yeah. Thank you because I
always feel in terms of description
that I do as little as I
can possibly get away with.
[ Laughter ]
And that the goal is to make the
reader -that that's one of the kinds
of work that, at least in
short stories, I feel I'm going
to shove off onto the reader,
I'm going to put in some detail
and then I imagine that what
they see is probably different
than what another reader sees.
Having said that, there are a
couple of stories in Get in Trouble
that are different than the other
stories in the sense that I set them
in places where I had
lived for a long time;
Florida, Carolina and Boston.
And those are all places that I
lived as a child or as a young adult
and then came back to as an adult,
and so I had this double
layer of experiencing them.
And so I think probably
the most unusual location
in those stories is the Land of
Oz theme park up in the mountains
of North Carolina,
which was a real place.
In fact, you can find lots
of pictures of it online.
I went there many times as a kid.
It was really kind of
a boring theme park.
You walked down a yellow brick
road, there was a gondola,
there was a fudge shop,
and at different sort
of stations you would see
part of the story acted out,
so it was fun to put
that in the book.
And I see that we are at time so...
>> Thank you.
>> Yep. You can ask
me at the signing.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.